Okay.
And we're back to wrap it up.
We just stepped outside.
Sacrifice the sacred
plant to the fire gods.
If you try to just put Brian
in a better state of mind,
I think you feel like a lot of
people are attacking you and um,
I,
I get attacked a lot nowadays.
I know you do.
I talked about that earlier,
but we're not attacking you.
And one of the things that I think
that's real important that I brought up
earlier is B,
be generous to a point
where it's indefensible.
Be Generous to a point where you know,
you people know that what you're doing
is you're doing it all for the right
reason,
I think.
I think if you're a listener,
you know that already
what I did for comedy,
and that was the one thing I started
screaming at Dunkin was like,
you don't understand how
much I do for comics.
My free time is devoted to 100% of
doing shit for free for other comics.
Now,
if they will tell you what,
I will tell you this though,
there's a lot of clubs over the
years that have had this theory that,
well,
you're lucky to be getting the
stage time and a part of comedians.
We don't respect ourselves.
We were like,
absolutely,
you're absolutely right.
But the other part is like,
fuck yeah,
but I'm also not driving to pass a dean
yet fucking editing audio software for
you.
I'm not fucking doing all this shit.
That's not the same as saying like,
yeah,
you should be listening
what you're doing.
You know?
I mean,
listen,
this is what you're doing.
You set up a beautiful thing right there.
They ain't bad.
There's nothing wrong with that.
And you know,
when I asked you about how many shows
do you want just to sort of eliminate
people as to what you're doing?
Okay.
I like what you're doing.
I like a lot of shows that
come out of what you're doing,
but I think that we have to always be
very careful that if there's any money
that's ever taking place in,
in any sort of a thing
where you're selling comedy,
comedians get super defensive and super
sensitive when you're selling a show and
the comics are going to go up and do
their standup and they're not going to get
compensated from it,
but yet they know that
money is exchanging hands
a show that people didn't
use it as a workout room.
For the most part I,
these are people that just like fucking
around like not actually like I'm
selling in.
Plus the fact that there's like seven
or eight people usually on each one of
these shows.
I think it's a little
different than if I were like,
hey me,
Ari and you are doing a show at
the Hollywood and scales and stuff.
While you wouldn't have it.
First of all,
the reason why you get to control this
money at all is because I gave it to you
because I don't,
I can you to rent that place out.
And since then I'm like,
look,
I'll give you all my money from my shows.
Right?
So you chose,
we'll sell it.
You do.
Yeah.
It shows I do,
or 90% of the shows that go on there.
Well,
I do them every week.
You say you're not lot.
Okay,
let's onsite nineties.
It's more than half.
More than half.
And that's more than pays the rent.
Right.
The,
the idea being that I think
when a comic knows that you're,
even if you're only making
150 bucks to a comic,
that's like,
why doesn't he make 50 and give us 50?
That's how they think
you're selling standup
comedy.
This is why,
if,
uh,
the fact that you guys
are doing all this to me,
I'm like,
all right,
bottom line.
Each one of these shows for going in
there and being there for five hours for
going in there and putting
together all these comics,
uh,
putting,
putting up advertising
and making posters for it.
Uh,
all the,
all this,
all this shit.
If it's not worth $150 is not
worth $150 and I'm not doing it.
If I'm getting this much
trouble for 150 bucks,
fuck bucket,
then I'm not doing,
hold on,
hold on.
A 15 bucks a ticket,
150 bucks,
even at 60% I'd say maybe on average after
I'm saying the average after tax that
I get after paying the host and comics
or whatever is usually about 150 bucks.
Well,
look,
if you spending money paying the comics
and you feel good about that and you
can,
you know,
you could sit down with them and say,
look,
I'm,
because you know what it
the only reason what it is,
it's whoever you heard it from or
whatever whispers you heard it from.
And Dunkin for some reason
who's been on the show?
I think $15 yeah,
but dunk,
it's been on one show.
I like it.
We'd like to 15 bucks.
We go to the comedy store.
It's just like,
well it's something nominal so I get it.
I get it man.
I get it.
But I'm just saying that after that.
I know what you're saying.
You're saying that you,
it's not worth it to me.
I don't give her saying you doing a good
thing by creating the spot for them to
warm up and they don't appreciate that
and that if you're not at least getting
something out of it like 150 bucks,
you're not going to just doing it.
Honestly.
You know how hard it is,
like devoting like almost every Friday
to being somewhere and on fact of that
being on there for like five or
six hours and that's called a job.
I completely understand that.
The worst night ever,
but two comedians,
they're also doing a job too and
they're also selling something valuable.
Their work in their materials and they
know that a unit though you are putting
together a promotion,
the promoter shouldn't be the only
one that's getting money out of it.
No,
and they don't.
Well they,
well,
we need to work that out,
that that should be an,
you know what it should be?
It should be each one of the
comics that come on it either goes,
Hey,
can I get $20 I'm like,
okay,
I'm not criminal.
Yeah.
Well you,
you want them to ask for money.
If you are somebody that that are like,
no,
I think I need to be paid.
I don't think I need
to deserve comparison,
but compared to me,
I will do almost any show for free.
I never care about fucking money at all.
Okay,
Brian,
but your $450 what's that?
Hold on.
Just so you know,
$30 to an MC is 20 paid tickets after the,
I get it.
But for comedy,
I don't want to get
paid for the most part,
I don't think that you need to be gay.
I have fun.
So why don't you give
up his mind to people?
Why don't you give up the money that
people give him 20 bucks a piece.
I'm 40 bucks is what I do.
But you have the deal happen.
Yes,
I haven't got why do you
think first time we did that,
why do you think that
pose in any comics that I know that
many people have asked for money,
but just because of poor doesn't mean
there's less or more deserving of that
money.
No one's five to a spot for 15 minutes.
I don't care if you do a
spot for 50 minutes to Joe.
I don't deserve that or less than him.
No,
no,
no one.
The only time I really ever
pay somebody as if I know,
uh,
for,
for these shows,
right.
If I know this person would appreciate it,
you know,
like the like,
dude,
thank you so much man.
You know,
I fucking have no money
and stuff like that.
But when it's somebody
that's pretty comfortable,
like,
like I feel like I'm
very average pace signup.
Like if it's something like
me cause security cutter,
I don't want you to pay me and I,
I'm not doing it for money and this show,
this show is always been like when,
hey,
I got this room in the ice house,
you want to do it.
It's like a workout room so I don't,
I consider this more like,
do you want to come do a really
good audience at a workout room?
Well then here's,
here's what you should do now to charge.
No cover told him until the ice house,
hey give me 50 bucks,
I'll pack this place,
charge no cover and there was no problem.
Absolutely.
That's a great idea.
Great idea.
Because you know why I took my door,
I'm not sure.
I'm not in it for money and
I'd keep it as low as possible.
Anybody who asks for a copy and give
it to him and I still get the rest of
charity,
not names,
I don't want the responsibility.
Somebody else is going to
completely do the desk.
A desk squash show there.
It's very difficult.
[inaudible] you're not in it for money
and then say you need a certain amount of
money or you won't do it because it's,
in my opinion,
uh,
if,
if I had to be asked,
hey,
every Friday you have work,
you put them through it.
Yeah.
If you have to go here,
you have to sit here and record,
you know,
and then,
and then in DC,
those podcasts usually go from
like three to five hours a lot.
The podcasts because some people don't.
Oh,
those pockets [inaudible] to put it
all in the hands of the Ice House,
give the ice house to contact numbers
for all the people that want to go.
That's what I do.
That's what I did.
Have him pay it.
That's what I do whenever
I don't want to do it,
I'll pay it.
They pay their headline is 100 bucks.
I was always helps people.
He kind of was always a thing,
a hundred bucks for headliners,
except for those fucking money they
have the on the staff and they have,
you mean they have to.
It's true.
That place especially has got so much
history behind it and the place had been
around for 50 plus years.
It's such a great place,
but I think that we gotta be real
considerate of of comics and the fact that
comics have a legitimate gripe when it
comes to worrying about someone making
money.
I mean,
it has to be explained,
I think in a,
in a thoughtful manner and not in this
knee jerk sort of angry Yeley sorta
shouty type away other people when you
don't even come to me and talk to me.
Well we're friends.
Fuck you've Duncan Trussell oh,
come on man.
See this is,
this is exactly what I'm talking about.
This is fuck Dunkin.
Stop Man,
stop.
Look,
this is this kind of why because it
tells you on a podcast because he's,
you know what?
I'm just done.
I've done so much for that dude and
he just pretty much attacked me.
I was like,
fuck him.
Well,
you know what?
If he had no point,
no place to stabbed with a pencil,
shit playing.
If he had no point.
If you have no place to
to talk to you about this,
there was no argument
there then it would be,
it would have no impact.
The reason why it has somewhat of an
impact is because it is an arguable
position.
Is there any ever a way to talk
about it where someone says,
let's just say this argument,
say,
Hey,
so and so you should pay this much money
to so and so and instead of going like,
what the fuck I do this and
this instead of going that go,
well,
let me think about that.
Why should I or shouldn't I pay this
person this much money or less money or
more money and just having a
nice conversation about it.
Yeah.
Now I,
that's why I don't think
it's worth it to me.
Well I think you took on a job then you
didn't quite know how much time it was
going to take.
I do take on stage.
How do you want to call the people and
schedule The times and have them come in?
It is how many $15 I went from going
to doing open mikes with a lot of these
people that I have on these shows or
just going to like different clubs and
doing stage time and never doing
real shows with these people.
Right.
You know,
so when I decided to
take on this crazy shit,
it wasn't more like,
Hey,
I got this access to this room.
I can make a show and we can all together
and we could have a show once a week.
It'd be cool.
And so you wouldn't think of
it as a financial decision?
Never financial fun.
Absolutely.
One of the,
one of the things we were talking about
that conversation with magical and you
and they're at the ice house though,
those nights where like one of the
things we were all saying is like,
and we'll just take the money,
not not them,
we will,
it will be us,
but how much,
how many texts did you have to sell
to get $150 at 15 bucks apiece?
Average average.
I think that thing holds 75 or something
like that and sometimes they stuffing
10 so 10 people and you only get,
you'll take taxes out of that.
So you only get 60% of that.
Huh?
I'm trying to think how many tickets you
would have to sell to go over that 150
mark that you normally,
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I don't get 100% of the door.
You got 60% of the door.
I think so something like that.
Do I know what to do about any of this
shit anyway because I think I'm literally
don't want to talk about,
I made a mistake as well and I just handed
it over to you cause the first couple
of shows when he's getting half of that.
But when I just handed it over to you,
I should have said let's sit down and
figure out where this should go and that
we should have the rent
paid for and the insurance
I,
to me it's not even worth it to me.
I'll go,
I'll go.
I'll go somewhere else for once a week.
And do comedy somewhere else and enjoying
myself and not get paid for it and
just have fun and not dead.
Last thing I do is like,
thank you so much for letting
me have this stage time.
Fucking you should pay me.
What the fuck I might talk about it.
No,
no.
That's not the way people are saying it.
Then assign one of those guys comedians
you feel attacked all the time.
Anything attack by fucking Jane.
More getting attacked by Duncan Trussell.
I'm getting attacked by fuck.
Just blockchain warrants or
whatever and this never a problem.
Tack by everybody.
What does that mean?
Attacked?
What does that even mean?
Not Exactly.
What does that mean?
They're saying a thing that I
liked about something to do.
I'm going to fucking do this to you.
I'm going to get that to you.
There's a patio.
There's a path with least
resistance out there.
I know it's kind of not bringing it
up on a podcast and getting into it so
everyone knows about this
and thanks a lot guys.
What are you talking about,
Ryan?
What are you talking about man?
You make it impossible to talk to you
about anything when you react this way,
turn this into some crazy
situation that it's not,
you know,
I,
if you,
I can understand you don't
want it to book a comedy show,
I can understand that being a
tremendous time consuming thing.
Well listen,
let's all talk about this and figure out
a way where we can have a show that the
ice house books let's
they're professionals.
That's what they do.
What am I doing is I'm married to
an ice house chronicles and uh,
I will make it just,
you know,
some other thing.
I'll make it just like a green room while
somebody else can do the room and I'll
have nothing to do with that room.
So Brian,
Brian,
just so you know,
this reaction we're getting from you is
the normal reaction we get from you when
he brings something up.
So does that make it more likely
for us to bring things up to you?
Are less likely to be open and honest?
I tell you why.
Because honestly,
I am so fucking busy that I don't
even need to deal with any of this.
You know?
I would rather just do this podcast,
be happy,
do everyone else's podcast,
be happy and not have something that's
such a big deal of that I thought was
just helping friends out
to you got a good point.
I think you've got a good point in that.
I think it is a lot more responsibility
and a little extra thing that you have
to chew on every week and I think it can
still be done and done through the ice
house.
This way the icehouse
pays people and we'll,
we'll set aside a chunk of it so you
can get paid for running the icehouse
chronicle tickets,
plus pay the guy,
you know what,
what,
or I can just do the exact same thing
I was doing and any comic that wants to
get paid,
we'll tell,
well,
I'll give them my man.
You can't ask people to ask for money.
You know what all I do at the time,
I go,
hey,
you want some cash?
And then they go,
no dude.
And I'm like,
okay,
okay.
Well those people,
how many times did that happen?
A lot more than you would think.
All right,
well get out of here.
Don't worry about it.
It's not stupid talking about it.
You don't want to become one of
those guys that doesn't pay people.
I don't even feel like talking about it.
I didn't know.
That's why it's hard to bring up.
That's why I say I'd like to get paid.
It's a hard thing to break,
but it isn't boring to me.
Podcasts be entertaining.
Not like,
Hey,
let's bust open Brian and fucking see
why he's thinking about financial shit.
No one's trying to bust you.
Open,
open on a podcast with,
we were at a fucking restaurant.
We could talk about all this.
I don't feel like doing
wrap this on a podcast.
Sorry,
I bring stuff up through Paychex.
Let's talk about,
very understandable,
Brian,
but you,
do you understand that you get into this
like really angry defensive position
with people that aren't
even attacking you?
Okay.
Do you understand that
you do that sometimes?
Listen,
man,
it's avoidable.
Sometimes you can talk in a,
in a rational tone.
I mean,
and I've been guilty of it
as well happened in her life.
It's easily avoidable with
like seven people right now.
Some of it to needle though.
Brian,
what you're doing is a great thing.
What are you doing with your
podcast network for those guys?
I'll drive out there just to do it and
what you said about like Freddy Lockhart,
like needing the network to get them on.
That is true.
It is all true.
It should,
they lead with you every time.
It's like,
Hey,
just so you know,
you do a lot of great things for me,
but I like to bring up this one thing.
If it's without help,
if you don't,
if you guys don't think that what I do
helps comedy or comics does your reading
as we just saw it as you must hate you,
right?
If you think there's a
better death squad idea,
I will gladly change the name of desk
quad to something just to make you happy.
You should do whatever desk.
What is you,
you're a part of death squad.
You know,
all of our friends are part of desk.
Why the fact that you and
Duncan don't talk or no,
it's disgusting.
You know what that's called,
trimming fat.
He's done a few things in the past
that I've let go and you know what,
I don't need that guy.
I've helped that dude so
many times and you know,
I mean been on his podcast once.
Well the same thing.
Dunkin is no perfect person,
but I love that guy to death.
I'm no perfect person
either and neither of you.
I think we can avoid these kinds of
conversations in the future if we just,
you just calm down a little bit man.
And what I said about being,
being in arguably you don't have to be a
straight deal with people.
You don't have to say,
I'm going to give you all my
profits and not so all the profits.
I'm saying you just completely reasonable.
Why are we talking about
this on a podcast is,
and that's what I'm talking about,
talking about fucking
farts and olive garden.
We don't have to talk about
only far it's an all barn barn.
There's nothing wrong with it.
This is a good conversation for all of us.
You know?
It's a good conversation
for me to understand that
sometimes you don't feel like
you're getting enough credit for all
the work you're doing for all those guys
that are on your network and in,
in,
in built this platform where a lot of
people find you find people because of
that platform.
We built it and I've been very supportive
of a Brian and I've been trying to
help it and I talk about it all the
time on this podcast and tell people to
subscribe to it and I tell people to
subscribe to it on Twitter and this the
only way to get it,
the icehouse chronicles just
to go through dusk squad.
No one's trying to stop.
It doesn't mean everything
you've ever done with it.
It's completely the right way to go.
You'd have to be able to bring up
something in order to get better.
Yeah,
we know we're not trying to
stop anything or just the,
the,
the icehouse thing can all be
worked out and I think it's,
it's a huge burden on your
back to financially when it
comes to figuring out who
gets paid and taking taxes and shit.
It's just not worth,
that's not worth it.
I just wanted to do comedy.
Well,
we can still tell you what you bought.
If you slap everybody 10 bucks,
it would be great.
You know what?
I just need an employee to go
and actually do that for me.
Goodbye.
[inaudible] to the podcast.
We,
we need to hire you and assistant,
so let's get going with that Asian guy.
What does he do?
That guy,
he's gone with the wind
dust in the wind.
Oh yeah.
It's dust in the wind.
I'm sorry if this was uncomfortable.
These gentlemen are uncomfortable
but unnecessarily uncomfortable.
It didn't have to be an Brian needs to
know that we all love him and he's doing
a good thing.
Just I think that's what it is.
You don't realize that
people still like you.
If I mentioned any sort of critique,
but it's still do like you last thoughts,
Brian,
please be positive.
Last thoughts,
Brian.
Ah,
Fuck Duncan.
Trussell oh,
come on.
How dare you after all that you go,
you go to fuck Duncan.
Trussell Yup.
Come on.
Let's think of something positive.
How to end this positive.
Ah,
goodbye.
Ari Shirt.
It's awesome.
Go sale yet.
Oh yeah.
Say say weeks or something like that.
So mine is this Brian Rabbit up.
Bring it all home.
Bring it all home in a positive way.
The fans.
No,
no,
it's not a contest.
There's no fight.
Don't make fights.
Yeah.
What do you mean the fans know?
They know how much I work for you guys.
Yes.
They know how much you work for us guys.
A nurse thing.
Hi Brian.
They know,
they know the time I put
in and doing all this shit.
Yeah.
Everybody knows that Tommy put into it.
Brian,
it's not bad.
Right?
So you wouldn't say I'm stealing
from comments that we do.
Brian,
I've never said you're
stealing from company Duncan.
He was out of line and he was upset at
you because he wasn't making an argument
about south by southwest and he didn't
feel that you should've been interjecting
what you were saying when he is,
our whole argument was about they offered
him to come out there and not pay him.
It's a silly emotional
thing between two guys.
They got dragged out in a public way
that was unfortunate and unnecessary.
He shouldn't have done that.
You acted in a very,
you know,
angry and you know,
fucking violent way.
And I had to actually separate the two.
You guys,
I mean the whole thing.
And now he's trying to leave the room
and you wouldn't let me leave the room
pushing towards him.
You were pushing towards now I was
screaming at him with my finger pointing
towards this direction.
We're moving towards him to the
point where I had to stop you.
What am I going to do?
I don't know if you're
going to do anything.
I didn't think you were
going to do anything,
but you were so mad.
I was mad.
All right.
And that's why I say,
why were you so mad in contrast
with Ryan and just be like,
Nah,
you're wrong,
Brian.
You know we love you,
right?
Do you know we love you?
Yup.
I think Brian,
we really do appreciate the work you do.
If we give you a lawsuit without you,
if we give you a big hug right now,
you're going to feel better.
No,
no.
He's going to feel way more uncomfortable.
No big hugs.
No.
All right.
We'll see you tomorrow,
Brian.
Calendar.
Mark.